hey guys and welcome back to the still
unnamed Park in the still unnamed
Spanish area and I've been thinking
about it I've been thinking about this
quite a bit and I really feel like this
area still suffers from a great problem
of not knowing what exactly it's going
to want to be and that's really an issue
that you'll probably see me complain
about in the future I'm actually
thinking of removing some of the footage
that I have so far over the park in the
future and just completely redo things
since there are just a couple of
complications though I would add that
does not necessarily have to count for
this building as well since I figured
this was going alright but the more that
I started deviating from the first kinds
of things that I did in this area the
more I also felt like I was deviating
from what I originally kind of wanted to
have and that's why I think it really
suffers from that problem of not knowing
exactly what it's going to be since I've
always really just had a vague idea of
what I want to do and I just kind of
took a risk with not developing the
thing further like planning things and
just instead of doing that dive right
into it and I'm probably just having you
know the the problems that come with
that right now
in other cases though I don't want to
make it seem like I have no idea what's
going on anymore what I have to do
exactly
it's just that I am not so sure if this
is actually the kind of direction that I
want to take in it and if at some point
in the future I just completely redo
redo some things and just remove all
kinds of things
that's probably why that being said
there is some work in this area on this
new building which although I'm not sure
how well it is going to work out in the
end it was a bit experimental I think I
can kind of keep it and also some work
on the log flume and as much as I am not
sure how the path layouts and rides are
going to be exactly in this area
I think the log flume will be there
definitely won't be removed but whatever
I do with that this should actually work
outs there is a pretty good planning for
that it's really just this area around
it would like the unfinished paths that
you can see where there is a bill the
lack of planning to actually make that
work in any case I think I have really
been complaining about this thing too
much I'm sorry I'm just really worried
about whether this is going to work out
right and whether it is going into a
direction that I like it to be and I
almost feel like let's get it over with
it with this area so I can move on to
which you might say but yeah you can
skip this area and do it later on which
is what you would always say but I'm
quite afraid that if I skip this area
for now that I'll barely even be able to
get back into it and yeah that's
basically why I chose to do like try to
do as much as I can right now
but yeah the current planning for it is
as much as it is a very vague planning
which I'm not really sure how much of it
I'll do is that I get a right in in that
empty area that's right next to the
white building with the tower that's
pretty similar to this building except
it's white and it's slightly different
rather than some parts which is
something that I've over always planned
because I'm not sure how well those
parts are going to end up in the end and
I might still look at the flat ride as
well and something that I'm still unsure
about is the queue that's gonna be
behind the building behind the station
building that is because there are
barely any plans when it comes to that
and everybody knows that I suck at
queues so bad so I really have to get
into that get like some people to tell
me how life even works when it comes to
queues and just kind of research stats
so that's what's going to happen this
building over here
I haven't even talks about this little
baby right here there is quite some
inspiration from the metropolis building
in Madrid which if you don't know
there's a building in Madrid at some
like pretty famous streets which is like
the Flatiron Building of Madrid in a way
which is a triangular triangular
building with a tower in front and I
like it quite a bit it's actually pretty
good
and it's all in the main idea of it's
really hard to make something look
distinctively Spanish since other
Mediterranean things and French styles
of architecture but also similar things
actually just quite similar so really
one thing that but a couple of the
things that set this thing that set this
area apart as something Spanish are the
Arabian influences and the fact that
there are some buildings that look a lot
like the real-life Spanish counterparts
where the pitfall of course was to make
them kind of look like Spanish buildings
and remind the people of said Spanish
buildings but not be complete ripoffs of
it so in that sense I am pretty happy
about the facades I don't want to be
just complaining about everything over
here I'm actually quite happy about the
facades and the way that it turned out
even though I do like to add a couple
more details to them and of course add
some extra path work because that's
definitely something that I need
underneath it but I'm pretty happy about
that it's just that the general paths
and how else I'm going to finish the
surroundings off set facades is
something that's just I've no idea
what's going to happen there so
hopefully that has actually going to
work in any case I decided to just
started working on the log flume for a
tiny bit to see how I can do the rock
work which in the end I know this almost
makes no sense but I always like to get
my girl peppers really large Yosemite I
think that's how you pronounce it rocks
in there since they are so incredibly
large and you can kind of just plan rock
facades with them they're more like a
facade planner because as you could see
those textures are really dark and
probably don't even fit with the theme
too well so I'm gonna cover that up with
lighter rocks at some point in future
but this was all just kind of planning
just getting the basic shape of the
mountain done that I wanted to do and
the main reason for doing this like this
and not just head into the rocks of
which I wanted to take her right away is
that many of the rocks that I wanted to
use for the textures most of which were
waverers medium rocks are just really
small so if I can give a small tip just
try building your rock facades with
whatever text - doesn't really matter as
soon as you get a shape that you like it
to be in get the texture rocks
you actually want to use and place those
on top of those though only in cases
where it works out as in right here the
textures that I use to plan the rock
work were into Texas that I wanted to
use but protections that I wanted to use
which is way too small rocks and so
that's kind of why I did that
and it's also slightly based on what I
did in the 32 by 32 Park actually that
32 by 32 tile park
I should probably refer to it as
shortleaf like that's a lot better idea
I'm actually going to do that but yeah
that was in a sense also a bit of
practice for this because I figured mmm
I could use that anyway so yeah that's
also why this thing is so incredibly
similar to that thing with having the
rock work and having the aquatex log
flume on top of it the 32 by 32 Park was
also bit of experimentation with path
works in a way that I might also try it
over here though I'm not too sure if
that's actually going to work in such a
large Pike but that's probably also a
story for another time honestly it's
just you know it's kind of my way of
saying that the the similarities that
this Pike might have with short-lived
lake aren't complete ripoffs but rather
short leave lake being a bit of an
experiments slash practice for this Pike
as basically that's what was going on
over there and I would really really
like to make some of those very typical
Mac log flume things because right now
this looks like an like an aqua coaster
right and everybody says oh you're
building a water coaster that's so cool
and I'm like no I'm trying to build a
log flume please no so I think that what
I kind of need actually to convince
people that this is actually a log flume
and to make actually look like a
convincing log flume it's one of those
very typical Mac water beds where you
have the drop with just a tiny amount of
water and where the the pure logs kind
of roll on these rolling things I don't
even know what to call them I'm not into
the technical stuff but basically those
very thin platforms that log flumes
usually have that drops on and that
doesn't really exist in water coaster
really like that's something that has
always nagged me it's either you go full
on water coaster which looks a bit weird
or you use the in-game log flume but for
some reason the in-game log flume as
soon as you have a drop that's like 80
degrees you still have like water that's
ever so slow and it makes no sense
so the ingame log flume is just
something that I despise it's not really
good so basically I'm trying to find
some way to make a log flume that looks
good so if I ever get the time or decide
to get off my lazy bum and actually do
something then I would really like to
make those log flume tracks things that
it goes down on in any case this is
something I think I've talked about in
the last episode when I wasn't supposed
to talk about it but I did in the end
the fact that I edit this small path
around the building with palm trees and
other foliage just to make sure that you
know that also looks good and that I
also have that where it's also paused
for a second right there I might have to
edit that out or not [ __ ] it
that was basically me trying to figure
out things I think because I usually
don't go afk when I'm recording hmm
whatever I was doing they're probably
taking like other music but that's
incredibly off-topic basically this was
that little thing in front of the
building that I wanted to have to make
that building not look like such a
standalone little thing in the middle of
the water and look so distanced from
whatever else there was in this area and
kind of connects it more to the water
area in the log flume with some fun
little fence action and fun little war
action and of course cool foliage so
that's kind of why that why this
happened I'm still trying to figure out
if there's like anything that I can do
with this border that I really like
since I'm RELIGIOUS kind of messing with
these this little wall right here and
it's still not pretty freaking out like
I wanted to get some good details on
those walls since it just kind of is too
striking of a contrast I think with the
rest of the building but so far it's not
working out too well so I might get into
that later on but I think at this point
yeah this was basically looking like
what it's going to look like in the in
its final form so this might not even be
its final form and of course there's the
rope fence over there like I I've
actually become addicted to that rope
fence it's whenever I have like any
fence over here whenever you know
everybody has this sometimes right you
have like a wall or the side of a path
and you want to get a fence in there but
no fence ever works like they're either
too small that too large or the colors
don't look right or the textures don't
match up and for some reason the rope
fence just always looks great I've no
idea how it even works but the rope
fence is just amazing um like in pretty
much every case except probably when
you're trying to build a modern arena
but then again that's pretty there's
plenty of fences for that so yeah that
rope fence is my newfound best lover
along with that one little flowery bush
in gardening one that's there's like
definitely there's some custom scenery
objects that I absolutely over use I'm
pretty sure that other people have this
as well but I currently over use the
rope fences still that one flowery bush
from gardening one pretty much anything
from a main street sets though I don't
know how much of an overuse the stuff
that is since you know they are really
big sets and a large home gardening is
just amazing I can't not use that and
yeah that was actually it's highly bit
of a debate about bricks and next to the
water where somebody said you can't have
bricks because you know they're not as
strong as a full-on war is and that's
water right there so that was actually a
really good point so that's why those
bricks were removed in any case that's
it for this episode thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you all next time
in which I'm not sure yet what I'm going
to do since I might redo it but in any
case I'll see you then